Then we can just
say, 'You are a dog now!'
Welcome back to mCoding.
I'm James Murphy.
Today, we're talking about the difference
between the type of an object
and the dunder class attribute
of that object.
And also how to change the class
of an object at runtime after it's been created.
It's that time again to talk about the best
sponsor - myself!
That's right, mCoding is not just
my YouTube channel.
It's also my
software consulting company.
We do software consulting,
contracting, training, and interview prep.
So, if you need any of those things,
please do reach out to me.
You can find out
more by visiting mcoding.io.
So, let's dive in.
If you have any exposure to Python,
you're probably already familiar with 'type'.
Pass in any object to the built-in type,
and it tells you what type it is.
Here, we're implementing the dunder copy for
the Animal class by getting the type of the object.
And then creating a new object of that
type, passing in the same name.
When we define equality
for our object,
it's also common to not want to
compare against things that aren't of the same type.
In this case, we just check if the
type of 'self' is the same as the type of 'other.'
And when we're defining a __repr__
for our class,
it's common to have the name of the
type in the string representation.
The reason that we even use
the type at all
instead of just hardcoding the name of
the class 'Animal' is because of inheritance.
Let's say we had a Dog class
that inherits from Animal.
Of course, printing out an Animal,
we get the expected result.
But if we create a Dog instead, then it still
prints out 'Animal' instead of 'Dog.'
But if we use the type of 'self,' then it'll
do the right thing in both cases.
For Animal, it'll print out 'Animal,' and
for a Dog, it'll print out 'Dog.'
So, that's your pretty typical use case.
As expected, 'type of self' gives you the
type of 'self.'
What else is there to say about it?
Well, if you read enough code, you might see other
people instead of using 'type of self,'
instead they're saying 'self.__class__'
Everywhere that you might
be expecting to see 'type of self.'
Instead, you see this other thing.
So, is one of them right and
one of them wrong?
Like, what's the difference?
Hmm, well, how about we look
at the CPython source code
and just get a feel for
how many times each is used?
Okay, so there are a decent number
of occurrences of 'type of self,'
and there are also a decent
number of occurrences of 'self.__class__.'
The fact that they're both pretty widely used
is a bit strange, but okay.
Maybe you need a flame war
to see which one's better.
Go ahead and comment #type or
#class to let me know which one you like better.
I mean, obviously, if you've got class, you
should go with...
Anyway, back to the differences
between them.
Rest assured that 99.9%
of the time,
they do exactly the same thing, and
you shouldn't worry about it.
The number one reason that people
choose one over the other
is just pure stylistic preference or just
copying code that already exists.
People that prefer '.__class__'
tend to think that
using multiple pairs of parenthesis like
this can be slightly less readable,
and people that prefer 'type' tend to
compare it to using other built-ins like len()
where you wouldn't typically call a __len__
you would just use the built-in len()
Realistically, in most cases,
just pick one and stick with it.
It just doesn't matter.
So, for the 0.1 percent of the time where
it might actually make a difference,
here are the actual differences.
The primary difference between using
'type' and using '__class__'
is that a class can
lie about its '__class__.'
The first way a class can lie is
just by assigning the '__class__' attribute.
If you were to use __class__, you would
see the lie 'SomeClass,'
But the built-in 'type' can't be fooled.
It will always give you the real type of the object.
The class could also lie like this: making
__class__ a property.
Or it could even lie by overriding the
__getattribute__ and specifically checking for __class__.
I mean, if you do this,
you must have incredible job security.
Now, as obviously wrong and bad as
doing something like this seems,
maybe if someone's doing this,
they have a good reason.
There's probably some testing mock
library somewhere that depends on this behavior.
So, that's an actual functionality reason
to use __class__ over 'type.'
One big thing to watch out for though is
not an object lying about its class,
but an object changing its
class at runtime.
Getting back to the Animal
and Dog example,
we can see that we can
actually assign to the '__class__' attribute.
So, we can create an Animal.
If we use 'type' or __class__,
we see 'Animal.'
Then we can just say,
'You are a Dog now!'
At which point, both 'type'
and __class__ now tell you 'Dog.'
That's right. It's not just lying to you
and telling you that its __class__ is 'Dog,'
but its type is actually 'Animal.'
It is actually a Dog now.
This can obviously go wrong in
so many ways.
For starters, the object was created
and initialized as an Animal.
If Animal defined an __init__ function,
that would have been called here,
but if Dog had defined an __init__
function, in this case, it didn't.
But if it did,
it was never called.
So, the Dog part of this Animal may
not have been initialized.
You could also do it
the other way:
Start with the Dog and then tell it,
'You're just an Animal now.'
Just like before, whether you use 'type'
or the __class__ attribute, they both agree
it starts out as a Dog
and then it becomes an Animal.
If you try calling a method that only Dog has,
that Animal doesn't, you won't find it.
This is also, in general,
not a safe operation,
although it kind of looks like upcasting,
which would be safe.
In this case, it suffers from kind of
the reverse problem as in the previous one.
Here, this is initialized as a Dog,
and it may contain Dog-specific state.
but the Animal class doesn't know
about any of that state,
and it might end up accidentally misusing it
because it doesn't know that it's there.
But you can do even weirder
because the new type that you're turning it into
doesn't have to be related
at all to the old one.
It doesn't have to be
a superclass,
it doesn't have to be a subclass,
it doesn't have to be anywhere in the MRO.
So, before, Bork is an Animal, and then he's a Car,
and this is made possible because,
in order to convert from one class to another,
there's pretty much only one restriction,
and that is that the classes need to have a compatible layout.
Well, how's it even possible that an Animal
and a Car have the same layout?
Didn't the Animal have a 'name' attribute,
but the Car doesn't?
Most Python objects are just a
wrapper around their instance dictionary,
which you can see a proxy of
by accessing the __dict__ attribute.
This is why it's possible to set and delete
arbitrary attributes at runtime.
This means you shouldn't have any
trouble converting between any two normal classes.
It is possible to have classes that don't
have compatible layouts, though.
For instance, if you use __slots__ in one
but not in the other.
If you're trying to mutate the
class of an object,
the 'to' and 'from' need
to have the exact same slots.
So, if one has slots and
the other doesn't,
or if they have different
slots, then they won't be compatible.
You'll also have trouble converting
to or from most built-ins
or anything that inherits from them as those
typically have their own custom layouts.
So, how about an example where you
might actually want to do this that's not totally crazy?
I mean, it's still mostly crazy
but not totally crazy.
This one's actually straight out of the docs,
so you know it can't be too crazy.
When you define
a module in Python,
you have basically no control over
the type of the module object that's created.
You just write your .py file, and then when
you import it, somehow magically, a module is there.
By default, modules
have the built-in 'ModuleType`.
But modules are objects just like everything
else in Python, so you might have wanted to
customize the behavior of your module.
You can actually do that by defining your
own module type, and then setting the '__class__'
attribute of the current module to be that
module type.
In this case, we're just modifying '__setattr__'
so if someone sets a value on our module like
a global variable, then it'll
print out a message.
But in theory, you could do whatever logging
or other behavior that you want.
The other use case I have is a way of deserializing
in-memory representations of objects.
Suppose I've got some data stored in a class,
and that class has some non-trivial internal state.
Then, suppose that I want to restore or
deserialize an object that had a given state.
Say, 'x' was 1 and
the internal state was 4.
Depending on the structure
and implementation of this class,
it may be difficult to construct
an instance that has this given state.
You may not know the sequence
of events that led it to be in this state,
or you may not want to repeat
that sequence even if you know it.
Instead, you might like to just have that
object sort of pop into existence with the given state.
So, what we'll do is create a Blank class
that has a compatible layout.
Then, we can just reach
into the object
and update its instance dictionary to
match the exact state that we're looking for.
Finally, modify the '__class__'
to be our desired class.
At this point, once again, 'type' and '__class__'
will agree that the class is 'SomeData.'
What might have been cons or points to
watch out for before can now be used to our benefit.
Creating an object this way doesn't
go through any of the normal mechanisms.
It doesn't get initialized with its '__init__,'
it wasn't created using the '__new__,.
And it didn't have its metaclass's
'__call__' called either.
Now, normally, you would
want all those things to happen.
But in this case where you just want the
object to pop into existence at a known given state,
maybe you don't want those
things to happen.
If you're familiar with the built-in 'pickle,' this is
similar but even more extreme than what 'pickle' does.
'Pickle' will create the object
using the '__new__' of the class.
And then it'll update the dictionary, or if you
have a '__setstate__' defined, it'll use that instead.
But a class's '__getstate__' and '__setstate__'
may not be something that you control,
especially if you didn't
write the class.
Additionally, that representation may
not be just a copy of the instance dictionary.
It could be compressed or just different variables
stored or some things just recomputed once it's unpickled.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
if you can use 'pickle,'
then you should definitely
use 'pickle' over doing this.
But if you need to,
this is one use case.
Once again, I'm James Murphy.
Thank you for watching.
If you enjoy the content,
please do subscribe.
And if you especially enjoy my content,
please consider becoming a patron on Patreon.
As always, thank you to my
patrons and donors for supporting me.
I really appreciate it.
Slap that like button an odd number of times,
and I'll see you in the next one.